-We have exactly two shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters."
-♪ 12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ Two days l-e-e-eft ♪
-That's right. Every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a swag-a-docious
Christmas sweater
from the
Countdown to Christmas Cabinet.
Since there are two shows left,
let's open door number 2.
-2.
-Yeah. Where we going?
-Down this way.
-Ooh!
It's over by -- close to me.
All right.
Whenever you're ready.
Yeah, go for it, bud.
Oh, wow.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
Thank you very much.
-Yeah.
-Can we --
-That's crazy.
[ Laughs ]
Can we dim the lights?
Can we dim the lights
for this guy?
Look at this.
Yeah -- ooh, that's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone,
look at your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down!
Quest, can I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
112!
Where you at, 112?
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go.
♪♪
Come on over!
Hey!
Hi!
Nice to see you.
It's a pleasure.
What is your name,
and where are you from?
-My name is Afsani.
I'm from Iran.
-Hey!
Welcome!
Thank you for being here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome, welcome,
welcome to our show.
-Thank you.
-And New York.
It's a little chilly outside.
-It is.
-You need a little bit
more than that.
-Of course.
-Yes, I mean, it looks gorgeous,
but this -- do you have
anything like this at home?
-No.
-No?
Would you like
to try this on for us?
-Of course.
-Yeah, this'll be fun.
Here, I'll help you out.
Thank you.
Go through there.
There's no real right way
to put it on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go. Oh.
-I'm stuck.
-Are you stuck?
-No.
-No, you're in.
Wow, look at this.
Are you kidding me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You look gorgeous!
Look at this.
Wow!
-Thank you!
-You look fantastic!
What a model.
Thank you very much.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations.
Thank you for being here.
Oh, please, I appreciate it.
Give a round of applause.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was fantastic.